- I always like to close out with one last
feel-good story to bring
you some joy possibly.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat jingle)
(crowd applauds)
We've all read the headlines
about how much these past few years
have affected kids' mental health
and that's why I love what one
California teacher is doing
to support her four- and
five-year-old students.
Each day she does an
emotional check-in with them
to just gauge where things are with them.
Every day of the week is
different for all of us.
So check out Feelings Fridays.
- All right, really quick,
I would like to do our Emotion Check-In.
If we're feeling happy today,
you're gonna show me a number one.
If you're maybe feeling
a little bit sad today,
you'll show me a number two.
You don't have to show
me yet, okay? Hold on.
If you're feeling calm,
remember calm is just content.
I know that's a big
word, just feeling good,
you're gonna give me a thumbs up.
If you're feeling mad, you're
gonna give me a thumbs down.
So right now, I just want
you to close your eyes,
take a deep breath in
your nose, (inhaling)
out your mouth, (exhaling)
and think about how you feel today.
(audience cheering)
- I love that!
Let's get this ultra-caring
educator in here
watching on CW59 in Fresno.
Say hi to Kristin, everybody!
(audience cheering)
Oh my God, first and foremost,
thank you so much for being an educator,
it's so important what you're doing.
Thank you so much.
I love, I love, love, love this idea.
How did you come up with this?
- Two years ago I started
doing it with my kids
and it was just a quick
like, thumbs up, thumbs down,
how you guys feeling today?
What I started noticing was that the kids
really wanted to elaborate and talk more
about the things that
they've got going on,
but with our busy schedule,
we just didn't have the time.
So what I decided to do this year,
was have designated, carved-out time
where they can just talk freely
about what they've got going on.
With these times, it's always
voluntary, I don't force them.
Now they get to be able to elaborate
and talk about the things that
they've got going on as well.
- Absolutely!
(crowd applauding)
It's such a healthy exercise
for all of us to do,
not just our kiddos.
Thank you so much!
You are such a gift and such a blessing
with what you're doing in your classroom.
It's so important.
I hope this catches fire,
I hope a lot of other
teachers clue into this.
It's really, really cool.
I'm liking your posts right
now, all right Kristin?
(ding)
All right, and that's not all, girl.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am,
so they're gonna be
writing your school a check
for $1,000 in your honor.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
- Absolutely, thank you so much Kristin.
Thank you to all our guests
today, Quinta Brunson,
Sheryl Lee Ralph, Lisa
Ann Walter, Kate Flannery,
LaToya and Lawrence Zarian.
Y'all have a great day and if it's not,
do an emotion check-in
and try and change it.